all right happening on Friday 8 news now
is giving back to the community on our
Founders Day of caring this year we're
supporting three local non-profits eight
news now's Candace Charles stop by NV
Energy where you can drop off donations
well you know in the energy they provide
energy services for 1.5 million people
throughout the state and now they're
helping us gather donations for our 27th
annual Founders Day of caring so what
you can do is help us fill up these two
boxes pretty simple come on by and of
course I have Angel Williams here with
me from Envy energy tell me how simple
it is for people to come on buy and
donate it's very simple to come on down
and donate we're conveniently located on
the corner of Sahara and Jones our lobby
is open on a weekday basis from 8 AM to
5 p.m these boxes are here in our lobby
we invite you to come on down and
participate with us absolutely and we're
raising this all for some great
non-profits in our community of course
the Maryland project which helps out
young women in our community as well as
Helping Hands which helps out seniors in
our community and we're also going to be
raising some money for Hope link tell us
why you guys decided to partner with us
on this occasion yeah at NV Energy not
only providing electric gas service is
important to us but also providing
Community Support so anytime we can
support a partner like 8 news now and
doing the founders day donation drive we
like to participate we get our employees
engaged we like to engage with our
customers and make it convenient and
easy for them to participate two great
organization Helping Hands of Las Vegas
Valley and also project Maryland great
Partners to support absolutely we
appreciate you guys help thank you so
much for chatting with me angel
don't forget you have until June 16 to
make your donations of feminine hygiene
products for project Maryland and
non-perishable food items for Helping
Hands
and if you're wondering where to donate
you can do so at the Findlay location on
your screen right here you can also drop
off your donations at NV Energy and both
Southwest Medical locations on the east
and west side of town